rebondissements avant même le décollage
d'Air Force One pour le Canada avancez
importante dans un dossier qui a causé
des turbulences entre Ottawa et
Washington
le Parlement les langues se déliente a
pris qu'une entente a été trouvé entre
les deux pays sur les migrations
irrégulières selon plusieurs sources le
Canada serait ainsi en mesure de
colmater la brèche du chemin Roxane en
échange
Ottawa aurait accepté d'accueillir 15000
migrants par les canaux officiels je
sais que vous avez rien à savoir autant
que moi mais ça va être bientôt le cas
là ils vont vous aurez des détails
prochainement préparation et en
prévision de la visite de Monsieur Biden
beaucoup de choses ont pu être faites
plus rapidement dans les dernières
semaines selon nos informations la
ministre des Affaires étrangères Mélanie
jolie et le ministre de l'Immigration
chantefraser on multiplié les efforts en
coulisses auprès de leurs homologues
américains ces dernières semaines pour
en arriver à ce résultat impossible de
savoir si les détails de l'entente
seront annoncés pendant la visite
présidentielle au plus tard
hier le Premier ministre avait laissé
entendre que le développement était à
portée de main on va continuer notre
travail
on ne sait pas quand la fermeture de
Roxane pourrait être annoncée les
autorités fédérales veulent agir
prudemment
le Bloc québécois attend avant de se
réjouir si l'objectif est atteint
c'est-à-dire fermer l'AXA mais permettre
au demandeur d'asile de faire leur
demande de façon régulière à travers
toute le Canada donc des engorger la
capacité d'accueil du Québec à ce
moment-là ce sera une victoire pour le
NPD le problème aurait pu être réglé il
y a longtemps en suspendant
unilatéralement l'entente sur les tiers
pays sur entre les deux pays s'il y a un
autre façon de régler ce qui se passe on
est ouvert parce que on doit régler ce
problème le Canada doit garder les bras
ouverts quoi cette experte et s'assurer
de la sécurité des demandeurs
régulier il faut s'assurer que ces
personnes-là puissent se faire en
sécurité sinon on sait et c'est normal
que ces personnes-là vont tout faire
pour entrer d'une autre façon c'est un
sujet qui n'est pas en tête de liste
pour Joe Biden mais pour Justin Trudeau
la pression baisse en fin d'un cran
c'est un gars qu'il pourra faire valoir
aux Canadiens au moment où son
gouvernement en a bien besoin lui qui
est sur la défensive depuis des semaines
sur la question de la gérant chinoise
ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada Ottawa